c'est inspirante et le futur des sages
oui bien sûr c'est rigolo c'était
d'abord un bon coup ça à mon cou c'est
pas besoin de ça c'est fantastique de
pouvoir faire ça de pouvoir montrer ça à
la télévision
moi je trouve ça bien quand même sauf
que quand même depuis 1960
on sera vous allez bien vous avez été
utile j'ai ouï je ne peux cette petite
qui atteint elles ont arrêté un des deux
ce qui a aidé à ce que l'on puisse voir
sa sont donc rien tu vois la preuve
c'est qu'on le montre à des ministres
questions pense claude à moi j'ai
effectivement je crois que wolinski a
beaucoup marqué jeu ce que je qui m'a
surtout marqué en 60 c'était la reine
des pommes c'est pas le reste depuis
j'aime beaucoup un ski mais je l' ai
découvert à l'époque les du début des
racailles dans l'arène des ports
qui était vraiment une bande dessinée
fantastique avec un style très différent
de celui qu'il est aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus chargé beaucoup moins dépouillé
mais
c'est vraiment les couverts et toi
yannick alors moi ça me fait penser
qu'on fout 6-3 6-2 à cécilia ce mouais
c'est vrai plusieurs semaines de travail
mené avec cécilia ça va pas fort mais
quand même mais non elle a décidé de
faire la chanson reggae son problème
chuté ce qui se passe je sais pas la
râperie tarbes le faire partager
enfin bon je veux dire fait sa vie je
fais la mairie et puis c'est con mais
c'est moi on effectue la quitter tu
gagnes est ce que tu vois qu'il ya une
relation de cause à effet mais c'est
possible mais bon là je gagne beaucoup
plus je veux dire au niveau physique
parce que vont là là c'est vraiment été
bon cette que je que je mets un casque
avec cécile ah bon c'est des petits jeux
des c'est pas tellement intéressant et
puis blond c'est rare que je fasse des
jeux blancs ce moment et là ce que je
veux dire c'est que bon ça lui manque
aussi de ce côté est ce que je dis ça
comme ça y est alala à l'effort à
l'effort l'évidence étant vraiment eric
blanc non c'est mon vrai nom fait
annoncer des bénéfices et un nom à dia
pathiraja un bénissez ci s'est prolongée
prix blanc parce que le savez marrer
tout le voilà ces courts et les moyen
efficace et là qu'est ce que tu veux
faire en tête-- au bataclan logiquement
on est un jeune homme là je suis en
train de
on est en train de chercher une autre
salle sur paris là ce sera sans doute le
jazz héros l'espace cardin ou encore
d'autres salles pourront faire le même
spectacle encore parce qu'il n'y a pas
eu d du monde mais on voudra encore et
encore plus de monde pour faire cela et
on a des tournées en province et puis
beaucoup d'émissions en marche bien
ouais pour l'instant j'ai pas tu trouves
pas que la meilleure arme contre le
racisme c'est l'humour pas que moi je
trouve que eric jeu-là d'or pour ça
qu'il soit là ce soir
il fait beaucoup d'humour c'est la
tolérance et donc une meilleure arme
contre l'intolérance c'est probablement
la tolérance est certainement l'humour
moi je j'en parlais du tombeur à jacques
pouget les découverts il y à 12 3 ans à
une émission de télévision où son
premier sketch était est effectivement
dans la peau d'un candidat à une
élection
blanc et je compte y ce matériel entre
la dérision la dérision terriblement
efficace non c'est non pas qu'il est
drôle à moi je crois que la meilleure
arme contre le racing s'est
effectivement l'humour et puis l'amour
aussi l'emploi d'enfants café au lait
plus ailleurs on va y aller